day will come when your joy will turn to
ashes in your mouth and you will know
the debt is paid hey youtubers it's
Charlie and Game of Thrones just
premiered its second trailer for season
four so just like last time I wanted to
do a breakdown of all the new things we
saw in case you're finding me for the
first time I'm doing a special game of
thrones season for countdown video
series that'll start in about two weeks
but i'll be doing histories of the Great
Houses character videos anything else
you guys want to say so it'll be a lot
of fun be sure to subscribe to get all
that stuff just like last week 2 i'll be
doing a Q&A video tomorrow night too so
i'll be picking 10 or 11 are your
questions from the comments on this
video careful for potential spoilers if
you'd want to know anything about season
4 but onto the important stuff now let's
get to that new footage somebody blow
the dragon horn first off the big
difference is the voice narration Arya
starts by saying her prayer and
explaining it to the Hound what it means
she adds names to it as she goes along
so by the end of this season there will
be more names on it number two here's
the first shot of steer the Magnar
offend he's played by joseph get a lot
of his parts from book 3 were given to
the Lord of bones last season but he's
finally arrived to the party just in
time for the siege of the Nights Watch
number 3 sophie Turner gets a voiceover
and shares a post red wedding moment
with Tyrion she didn't have a lot of
time to grieve last season as her
wedding to Tyrion was kind of rushed it
seems like she's mostly over the Tyrian
part and just grieving about her family
number 4 Jon Snow talks about the old
bear being murdered by burn gorman and
the other rogue night's watchman last
season burn gorman is actually returning
this season so John making a chance to
revenge him if you didn't know junior
Mormont is actually the father of Sir
Jorah Mormont who's currently serving
Danny in the East right now number 5
this is the first speaking scene from
Stannis this season he's drunk the
Melisandre kool-aid so much that he's
dedicated to the idea of this epic war
between the red God and the great other
so he's really trying to secure his
legacy this season I always loved how
all the scenes usually have burning
flame in the background number 6 here's
a shot of Danny's legions of unsullied
attacking marine it's hard to tell until
you see that bit of debris fly by number
7 here's another shot of the wildling
siege against the Nights Watch number 8
there's a voiceover scene from
Littlefinger talking to Sansa about
revenge if there's anything that
Littlefinger has been good at it's the
art of the long con he's like The Great
Gatsby person of Game of Thrones he
love Catelyn Stark as a child but she
was too far above him so he rose to
power and dedicated himself to crushing
the people he hated like the patheon's
and the Lannisters and creating a world
where he would be able to be with her
although he did kind of end up going
crazy along the way number nine Searcy
spits Tyrians lined back in his face it
goes the day will come when your joy
will turn to ashes in your mouth and you
will know the debt is paid it's actually
something Tyrion said to her during
season 2 number 10 this is the first
shot of shay we've seen in season 4 it
cuts straight to a scene of Tywin which
for book readers is a huge teaser of a
major plot point so I will not say what
it is number 11 Danny declares she will
rule this is her just dedicating herself
to fixing the problems of slavery and
terrible government in the east she's
faced with the choice of abandoning her
quest for the Iron Throne or helping all
the people she's liberated number 12 and
last one the trailer ends on a shot of a
white Walker this is the first season
for shot we've seen of one and it looks
a little bit different from what we saw
last year so they may have changed the
makeup effects just to make them look a
little more unique so based on this
trailer it looks like they're really
pushing the Valar morghulis team this
season all men must die as in everyone
must die although quick shout-out to
Danny from last season when she returned
with yes but we are not men so now it's
your turn let me know what was your
favorite moment from the trailer and
what are your biggest questions honestly
my favorite moment was them giving
Cersei Tyrians line as well as the new
shot of the white Walker I can't wait to
see a legion of White Walkers this
season don't forget I'm posting that Q&A
video tomorrow so feel free to ask me
any questions about Game of Thrones you
want I'm also posting a new Walking Dead
video tonight right now you can click
here to get all my other season 4
breakdown videos and you can click here
to get that Walking Dead review thank
you so much watching I'll see you guys
tonight high fives